lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
comparar distribuciones por ejemplo aquí
tenemos dos distribuciones de las
temperaturas que tienen dos ciudades de
eeuu durante el mes de enero esta es la
distribución para portland vemos que
hubo ocho días en los que la temperatura
fluctuó entre 1 y 4 grados celsius
mientras que durante 12 días la
temperatura osciló entre 4 y 7 grados
celsius y así para los demás días esta
es la distribución para minneapolis para
comparar estas distribuciones nos vamos
a enfocar en el centro y la dispersión o
la variabilidad de las distribuciones
esto es lo que vamos a comparar primero
vamos a tratar de compararlas a simple
vista no vamos a elegir una medida de
tendencia central como la media o la
mediana y calcularla precisamente lo
haríamos así en caso de que ambas
distribuciones fueran muy parecidas pero
si podemos hacerlo a simple vista es
mejor lo mismo hacemos para la
dispersión y la variabilidad en ambos
casos contamos con varias herramientas
estadísticas para calcular las la media
y la mediana no sé
para calcular la tendencia central y
para la dispersión y variabilidad nos
sirve el rango inter cuartil la
desviación media absoluta y la
desviación estándar todas estas son
mediciones que nos pueden servir pero en
muchas ocasiones podemos comparar las
cosas a simple vista en esta primera
comparación que distribución tiene un
centro cuyo valor es mayor o son iguales
si vemos la distribución para esta
primera ciudad para encontrar el centro
de la distribución podríamos considerar
la media aunque en este caso parece que
la media y la mediana son cercanas a
simple vista parece ubicarse cerca de 7
quizá un poco menor a 7 es en el rango
de 5 a 7 en donde podemos ubicar la
tendencia central la media o la mediana
en cambio para esta otra ciudad
pareciera que el centro está alrededor
de menos dos o menos tres grados celsius
así pues aún cuando no conocemos cuál es
el valor de la media una mediana de
estas distribuciones podemos decir que
la distribución de la izquierda tiene
una medida de tendencia central mayor ya
sea usando la media o la mediana podemos
decir entonces que la distribución para
por la
tiene un centro con mayor valor sin
importar si lo mires con la media o la
mediana y qué hay con respecto a la
dispersión o variabilidad si observamos
gráficamente el rango notamos que no hay
nada por debajo de un grados celsius y
nada por arriba de 13 grados así que
nuestro rango va de 1 a 13 incluso
podríamos pensar que las temperaturas
que se incluyen en esta clase son de 3 o
3.9 grados y de forma similar los datos
que contribuyen a esta última clase
podrían ser varias temperaturas de 10.1
grados por ejemplo así que como máximo
tenemos un rango de 12 grados en esta
distribución en cambio en esta otra
distribución vemos que tenemos un rango
aproximado de 27 grados con base en esto
aunque lo estamos haciendo a simple
vista en ambos ejes horizontales
correspondientes a la temperatura
estamos usando la misma escala esta es
una distribución mucho más amplia de lo
que observamos aquí así podemos decir
que la distribución de minneapolis tiene
una mayor dispersión o una mayor
variabilidad
veamos otro ejemplo aquí estamos usando
otra forma de representar los datos en
las olimpiadas hay eventos que tienen
competencias de varias rondas uno de los
eventos es el nado de dorso de 100
metros la gráfica de punto superior
muestra del tiempo en segundos de los
últimos 8 finalistas en la ronda final
la gráfica de puntos inferior muestra el
tiempo de los mismos 8 nadadores pero en
la ronda semifinal de estas
distribuciones que se muestran cuál
tiene el centro con mayor valor en este
caso es más fácil observar cuál sería la
mediana para calcular la media
necesitaríamos de un poco más de
matemáticas para calcular la mediana
contamos con uno dos tres cuatro cinco
seis siete y ocho datos la mediana se va
a encontrar entre el cuarto y el quinto
dato así que la tendencia central de la
ronda final es aproximadamente 57.1
segundos especialmente si usamos la
mediana mientras que para la ronda
semifinal
la tendencia central es tenemos 1 2 3 4
5 6
7 y 8 datos parece que la tendencia
central la tenemos justo aquí un poco
más de 57.3 segundos así pues parece que
la ronda semifinal tiene una tendencia
central de mayor valor que la ronda
final lo que es poco intuitivo porque
esperaríamos que los finalistas fueran
más veloces que los semifinalistas pero
esto es lo que nos dicen los datos la
ronda semifinal tiene un centro de mayor
valor esto lo vimos a simple vista
usando la mediana y esperaríamos que la
media también fuera más alta en esta
segunda distribución y qué pasa con la
variabilidad si vemos el rango de los
datos y nuevamente ambos tienen la misma
escala si observamos la variabilidad o
dispersión de la ronda final veremos que
es más grande que la variabilidad de la
ronda semifinal por lo que decimos que
la ronda final tiene una mayor
dispersión en algunas ocasiones podremos
encontrarnos con alguna distribución que
tenga un rango mayor pero una menor
desviación estándar por ejemplo podemos
tener datos que se encuentren muy
alejados entre sí y que el resto de los
datos se encuentran sumamente cercanos
una distribución como la que acabo de
le agrego su eje horizontal para que se
vea mejor puede tener un rango más
grande pero una desviación estándar
menor que la distribución que voy a
dibujar
tiene un menor rango pero una mayor
desviación estándar comparada con la
otra distribución puedo dibujar mejor
esta distribución de abajo esta tiene un
rango menor pero también tendrá una
mayor desviación estándar no siempre
será el caso de que al observar la
distribución tengamos la certeza sobre
algunas de estas medidas como el rango o
la desviación estándar pero en ejemplos
como los que acabamos de ver podemos
estar seguros de que a simple vista
notamos cual distribución tiene un rango
mayor o una variabilidad más alta y con
esto terminamos